hey Justin welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hey Dave thanks how can I help
I have a weird situation my I'm not
married we've been together for about
six years now we move from California to
North Carolina I bought a house he's
still in the military I got out in
California and that's what brought us
here and it was just going to be cheaper
and be easier for us to buy a house
anyway so that's what we ended up doing
this is before I listened to your show
and understood the debt and everything
like that so I bought the house and I
got a good-paying job
household income right now is about
120,000 but she's getting out of the
military in June of this year
mm-hm and so that'll drop her income
down to about 85 90 thousand she she
pays the mortgage on the house I pay the
4runner that's just the way that we had
been doing things and then we both
agreed to go in and tackle this so that
we can own the house you know within
five or six years it was probably May
this year I bought a 2018 4runner and so
the upgraded package so it was like
41,000 we put 11,000 down with a
trade-in and everything I know about
35,000 on it together we have about
20,000 in savings she essentially what I
got from her is that she kind of wants
to skip to baby step three that she
doesn't have any other debt that's our
only bet is the forerunner in the house
mm-hmm she kind of wants gifts to baby
step three to prepare to get out and so
that would put her pain you know the
normal mortgage and the gifts and all
the bills that we have and saving
everything else until she gets out of
the note there she still she teaches
dance on the side as well so she's got
additional income what's your question I
wanted to know if we should tackle this
4runner together and get this 35,000 out
of the way or if you think that we just
keep going about it the way that we're
going
her continued to save and then meet
tackle the forerunner and then
eventually when she I think you're
running into the natural tension that
occurs when you're trying to act like
you're married but you're not because
your vacillating back and forth between
acting like a married couple or acting
like roommates
and you and your vessels so it's my
bills her bills my bills her bills but
we did this and we did that and under in
a legal sense from Oh from the law
perspective there's not a we yeah you
have a roommate from from the
perspective of the law you see what I'm
saying and so if if she decides to walk
out the door
whoever's names are on these things or
who's going to be holding the bag
whoever's names are only savings
accounts what's gonna be there so your
and relationally you're struggling back
and forth and vacillating so you guys
can do what you want to do obviously
you're grownups and you've done very
well you're making 120 a year
congratulations you called and asked me
so I will tell you what I would do if I
woke up in your shoes okay yeah I would
get married tomorrow and then there
would be no your for one and a runner
your savings account your this it would
only be we and then I would work the
baby steps exactly as prescribed okay
that's what I would do I think you're
making really good money I think you pay
the stupid full runner off or get rid of
it before she gets out and I want other
lineup I want her to line up her career
for what she's gonna do as she comes out
of the military but you the thing is you
you just can't vacillate between you
know looking in the refrigerator and
going well that's my mustard I bought
that mustard you know back in or no
that's our mustard because we're we're
doing this together oh well I can't
decide and there's this it just pulls at
people parties there's all kind of
statistical research that shows you're
going to have substandard results in
your finances as well as other areas of
your life until you put marriage in the
equation and so you do what you want to
do I'm just an old guy advising you I've
got several reasons
for that advice but that's what I would
tell you to do if you were my little
brother that's what I would tell you to
do I'd say
get married and stop trying to play both
sides of this coin just do it and you
know you've been together forever anyway
you're doing life together it's a
technicality really but then you have to
say from that point forward we we have a
forerunner we have a house we have a
savings account we have a plan we are
going to submit ourselves to the baby
steps we are going to stick with this we
are going to go that route and and you
become French at that point we we right
and so that that's what I would do it
cleans up everything and then walk right
down it and if you want to say well you
know we're facing an emergency with the
loss of her income and so we're not
going to work the baby steps right now
we're just going to pile up cash and get
ready for a baby step that's not really
skipping the baby step three that's just
saying we're not gonna do anything right
now and pile up money if you want to
make that decision you can because
you're panicked about the loss of her
income I don't think I'm panicked about
the loss of her income though because AI
think she's gonna have another income
lined up she's got from now to June to
figure that out and B I don't know what
percentage of your income she of our
income once we're married that she
represents so that that's the other
thing you got to look at the variable